can you tell us about your character
butter butter is just he's obviously a
very overweight kid he's not really
comfortable in his own skin he kind of
he doesn't really fit in he's he's the
outcast he's the misfit no one really
knows who even his real name is even
though he's never moved around like
people have grown up around him but he
don't even call him by his real name
they call him as butter
a much much lower Niq name which the
movie very very well establishes why it
is loved you know well we often see
people like that or we've been them
ourselves you know in in school for
whatever reason and and sometimes you
see that people like that actually have
like an amazing talent or or they're
actually very there's something very
special about them is there something
special about this character butter yeah
I think his musical talent that's really
where it shines he is a I wouldn't say
prodigy but basically at that level of a
saxophonist
this is butter is one of those kids who
could walk into Juilliard pick up a
saxophone not even have a read on it and
still make it sound beautiful but his
classmates don't see that his classmates
they also they see him as that a kid is
who I snap especially made chair
especially made desk who sits by himself
who drinks two cans of coke and eats
he's just buffet style lunches that he
packs for himself it's almost ridiculous
the stuff food that we have had me eat
so the for the shoot but it's it's it
fits the character so if there was a
teenager right now that was in butter
shoes whether it was just a group of
kids doesn't like the person doesn't
even have to be something is you know
totally different it's just they got
pegged as the outcast which I know
happens well what would your advice be
to that person male or female um you
know you don't know that you are not
alone
you know there's someone else whether
that's at your school your church or
whatever whatever organization you might
be a part of you know it doesn't matter
so you're someone someone also feels
Emily you do whether you don't feel tall
enough or pretty enough or buff enough
or fast enough you're not alone everyone
feels that way everyone wants to be you
know the best that whatever it is and
things in high school fact is it doesn't
really matter after high school as soon
as soon as you graduate it gets so much
better everything just all the drama you
think you're dealing with in high school
it goes away pretty pretty quick as soon
as the capture on your head but prepared
but be prepared for the board on a
graduation so when you graduate you you
went to high school in Nevada I went to
high school in Henderson Nevada
graduated don't Las Vegas basically okay
now do you still go to is it UNLV you
yeah well I did go there for a little
bit and then I dropped out to pursue
acting a little more seriously it was
school would became a bit more of a
distraction for me so this way I had
more time for auditions and make a
little more money with just little side
jobs and focus on creating characters
and stories that other people were gonna
react to whether positive or negative
some of the challenge myself why did
your parents were they okay with that
with you leaving college um my dad
tattoo was always you know you should
you should at least attend at some point
but it's not necessarily he knows
college isn't for everybody took him
several several tries and years to
graduate college my joke is you know if
he went to cost the entire length he
when he would have been a doctor and
he's only got a bachelor's that's all
but you know it college isn't for
everybody sometimes it works out
sometimes it really is just that time
where you discover yourself but it is it
costs a lot of money to go to college
and if you don't have the money like I
don't you know you gotta make a living
somehow some other way and college is
gonna be there forever
so you can always take an online class
pretty quick and easy
I'm fairly inexpensive - so that's my
recommendation you and do what do what's
gonna save you mind do what's gonna do
what's gonna make you take those steps
to accomplish your goals so how did you
hear about this character and in this
film well my agents submitted me through
the many many acting website actors
access I think is will who we submitted
me through but it's like three or four I
submitted thermo so I'm not entirely
sure which one I drove in from Vegas and
Wow you know once the audition not
really not knowing that not having read
the script just read the scene not
really knowing what's going on
casting director tennis is she's amazing
she was absolutely incredible she calmed
me down she knew I this is what's gonna
happen here's a little secret so it
helps your character make sure I mean it
improves your performance you're gonna
read this scene we're gonna do it a
couple times well I'll send make sure we
get the best take to the director so he
can make a good decision then we're also
you didn't do a little shot of you
improvising a saxophone solo because
that's very important for the movie oh
okay yeah yeah well and I there wasn't
it wasn't even a saxophone to play so
yeah here's a ladle plates the most
complicated Charlie Parker saxophone
solo ever made
okay you ready no okay go so there's
some how I you know for several months
later I'm got the official casting so so
for several months you didn't know you
went back to college
no I'm I've been out of college for
about a year and a half now
oh sorry okay yeah but came down for the
audition several months later hey can
you do these couple additional scenes I
know you're in Vegas can you just do a
little video and send them to me so I
got my acting coach out there in Vegas
Paul Campanella who was amazing by the
way forever in Vegas market you need
demo reel he'll hook you up he's amazing
shot the two additional scenes send them
same day and then if you maybe a month
or so later yeah okay
director still like she's still in the
mix
want you to come in for a screen test
and also want to the director to meet
you so you can do Skype were you knew it
in person this match probably babe a
better for everyone scheduled do a Skype
interview we discussed you know what
Paul wants to do for the character what
how I connect to the character were
similarities lie and we try to build the
character around the similarities to me
to butter the character in the book and
what Paul's goals for the character were
and which kind of did a little trifecta
make it something it's a little more
three-dimensional did you read the book
I did I've actually read about three
times to Republic yeah I actually have a
copy of it on the set with me every day
oh wow and so you went back to Vegas and
you're working these jobs and you're
just doing that and you're waiting by
the phone at the computer is going
anything anything I think it was August
was the screen test and meeting with the
director okay all right I'm feeling
pretty good feeling really good
September comes around not feeling too
good
where nothing's happening I lost a
little home like they want with somebody
else I would have heard right now then
the week after my birthday in October is
like oh yeah yeah got the part
oh wow so I run out of my bedroom in my
underwear sharing to my parents and yeah
that that call woke me up sigh i worked
graveyard security so no I'm gonna say
11:00 in the morning and my agent call
yeah you got the part okay oh how was it
going to work that day I was I was
excited I was oh I can't say anything
can say anything can't say anything it
eventually came out survivor I don't
need this job man I got a movie I get
the lead role in the movie I'm feeling
pretty good
you